[Music]
now as someone that's always on the go
trust me sandwiches are my go-to that's
why i'm putting a delicious new spin on
a japanese classic adding some delicious
healthy tuna to a traditional katsu
sandwich trust me
the minute you bite into this
every bite will leave you wanting more
right ingredients oscar pan down
first of all
tuna now traditionally sandwiches
normally serve with either chicken or
pork but today we're going healthy
tuna steak from there some beautiful
panko breadcrumbs flour egg that's a
classic dredge okay in terms of when you
panny something granny smith apple to
give it a little bit more zest cabbage
to give that nice little bit of crunch
and texture a little bit of ginger
tonkatsu sauce classic with ketchup
worcester sauce soy sauce and such a
mirin
now sesame seeds additional if you wish
touch a chili if you wish but simple and
delicious right let's have 10 minutes on
the clock now nonstick pan clearly
because we do not want that beautiful
tuna stick in right get the pan on
now lightly season this tuna first okay
really important it's a very dense
protein super delicious but
really really important that we season
it okay before we flour egg wash
breadcrumb i'd also like a little bit of
a sort of chef treat i like to season
the tuna
with some lemon now lemon or lime zest
it doesn't matter but look
put that in there okay and now
the three stages okay
take your egg
crack that
onto a
nice flat surface
give that a little mix
i like to use whole egg okay which makes
it a lot more sort of
thicker sometimes
you can put water or splash of milk in
there but i like it nice and sort of
thick
therefore it keeps in the flavor and
doesn't allow my tuna to go watery again
just a touch of seasoning in there so
step one
okay flour egg bread crumbs get your
tuna roll it round that beautiful
seasoned lemon zest salt pepper already
it smells very fragrant into the flour
okay roll around the sides really
important
really important into the hands
and clap clap clap okay we're just
shaking off the excess flour from there
into the egg
okay lay it down
flip it over
roll the sides
and then back down
look all that lemon's still stuck in
there and then into your bread crumbs
wipe your hands
and then from there look
this is the magical bit flip that up
and just
just get your
crumbs over there first before you touch
it that way you don't have these big
thick fingers
now look
in
and what i like to do now is just get it
and sort of pack it in there okay push
those breadcrumbs down and that forms a
really nice crust
and that's texture there roll around the
sides
i know i sound slightly annoying but
roll it around the sides it protects the
tuna okay flip it over pat it down
now
pan now
pan
oil in get this really nice and crispy
okay
really important get it up hot
just slightly smoking and in
shake off the excess bread so it doesn't
burn in the pan and then literally lay
away from you okay
get that nice crisp sear really
important
now
the secret here is we're serving the
tuna nice and rare okay
check that color just lift it up
and look
back onto the heat
really important that we don't burn
these breadcrumbs i want that nice light
golden texture on there okay flip
tilt the pan it cooks the back of the
tuna okay
literally 30 seconds each side
and then look i'm going to turn that
back over and look at that beautifully
done
as it sits there
it's cooking nicely i'm a stickle for
seasoning fish and finish them always
with a bit of citrus okay
now from there little touch of olive oil
in there again
okay roll it round
and just tilt that down
and make sure you turn
clockwise the tuna and cook the back of
that steak
okay i want it nice and pink in the
middle i'm gonna turn the gas down
okay but as that comes out
i want to just literally hit that with a
little touch of chili just a touch on
there tuna is very dense very sweet and
a little bit of chili in there just
lifts that flavor up
time please
okay now
the slaw
i say slaw but it's almost like a sort
of
a delicious sort of
nice
fresh slaw
take your cabbage and literally just
grate okay
the secret behind this
is to make sure we got that really nice
fresh
crunch
to this sandwich okay slow in
don't worry about those outside leaves
just check
again
i'm going to turn this one more time
over look at that that's the color i
want that nice golden brown color okay
seems crazy i wanted i want the fish to
rest a little bit okay so i'm gonna take
out the pan
and let that rest cabbage nicely done
we'll change up
the texture
a little bit of
granny smith apple
time please
excellent granny smith apple cabbage
trust me
hey marriage made in heaven
again you've got red apples it doesn't
matter the flavor of the cabbage and
apple is delicious
right tuna
can come out now
and literally rest okay
but look at that color
so beautiful
let that rest
as that rest
fresh lemon juice just on the top and
just let that permeate and go all the
way through lemon juice inside the slaw
some fresh ginger
squeeze out that excess juice and just
slice that up okay
mix that in with the cabbage and the
apple now think of the flavors going on
there
okay you've got beautiful salt
pepper
chili
and then give that a nice little stir
now
that is so fresh
now
look it's starting to build those
flavors tonkatsu sauce
starts off with the ketchup time please
two tablespoons of delicious ketchup
a nice healthy lug of soy sauce
mirin in tablespoon and then some
peppery beautiful nice
worcestershire sauce in she goes
now from there
give that
a really nice stir
okay
now think about the texture
okay got a nice spicy ketchup
we've got the tuna set there
and this
is how we start the build take your
beautiful bread
and
now slice that down
now this sandwich as you know
traditionally
is normally served
with beautifully
pulled pork
or fried chicken
keep that size
nice and thick
and this
is where the magic starts
now from there get your sauce
okay
and layer that sauce on
time please
three minutes to go
now generous on this sauce cover that
bread okay
and then from there
the smell is incredible
okay
i'm gonna get a little bit more zest on
there to make that sauce very tangy
you'll see why in a minute
beautiful done
now
with your slaw
on she goes cover that bread
this is so fresh
and fragrant you only need to put that
beautiful cabbage
and
apple
and chili on one side
now cover the corners we don't want any
cheap sandwiches here
and then look
the flavor is amazing
the ginger inside that slaw just lifts
it
on she goes
over the top
and then
do you go into triangles or do you go
straight down
i'm from a council house so i go
straight down no post sandwiches in my
household
slice that there
i've got a little bit of extra different
sauce
i want to get excited about time please
and then just open that up
and sit that
on there
and trust me that has to be the positive
sandwich from any council estate in
britain bon appetito
[Music]
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck